on September the 19th 1991 a couple of
tourists while hiking through the Alpine
mountains that straddle the border
between Austria and Italy when they came
upon a grisly sight a frozen body with
the lower half completely encased in ice
they initially thought they discovered
the remains of an unfortunate
Mountaineer who maybe got lost or
injured and died in the snow or perhaps
they had stumbled onto something a bit
more blood-curdling like a murder victim
either way they did what any sensible
person would do and they alerted the
authorities as it turns out their
suspicions were off by a few thousand
years a murder victim may be more on
that later but definitely not a recently
deceased Mountaineer the body belonged
to a man from the Kalka lithic period
better known as the Copper Age he has
often been referred to as Otzi the
Iceman named after the odds all Alps
where he was found and he became
something of a sensation with him being
the oldest natural mummy in Europe today
we're gonna do something a bit different
here of our graphics as we explore the
story of a man completely absent from
the historical record there are no texts
no inscriptions no oral history to
provide us with information about his
family life his accomplishments or his
failures every single thing we know
about Otzi we learned by studying his
mummified body and studying the items
that he had on him when he died
[Music]
[Applause]
as we mentioned before the Iceman was
discovered by two German hikers named
helmet and Erika Simon on the ridge of
the fennel peak at an elevation of ten
thousand five hundred and thirty feet
the two tourists were venturing off the
beaten path when they encountered Otzi's
half thawed body so it's hard to say
with certainty when he first emerged
from his icy tomb extracting the mummy
from the snow proved trickier than
expected the first day the Simon's found
the body but make no attempt to remove
it the second day they brought a few
policemen who came armed with pickaxes
and a pneumatic drill but they had to
abandon the mission due to bad weather
the third day another attempt was
aborted because they could not obtain a
helicopter it wasn't until September the
23rd that Otzi was finally completely
extricated from the ice and taken to the
Institute of Forensic Medicine in
Innsbruck their archaeologist Konrad
Spindler dismissed notions that the body
belonged to a recently deceased
Mountaineer and said that it was at
least 4,000 years old scientists
realized the potential magnitude of the
finds and multiple teams went back to
the location where Otzi was buried and
continued excavations to see what else
they could discover meanwhile four
separate scientific institutions were
given tissue samples from the corpse to
perform a radiocarbon dating and they
all concluded that the ice mummy lived
sometime between 3350 and 3100 BC to put
that into some perspective Otzi had been
buried for over 600 years when the
ancient Egyptians began construction on
the Great Pyramid of Giza
in the meantime modern authorities were
more concerned over the complicated
issue of ownership with mr. regard for
future geopolitical sensibilities Otzi
decided to die
right next to somewhat of a
controversial border between Austria and
Italy according to the Treaty of San
Jamar Orlais from 1919 the border
between North Tirol which is in Austria
and south Cyril which is in Italy is
defined as the drainage divide of the
rivers in and etch however when it was
time to officially draw the borders on
maps the survey team made a mistake due
to heavy snow and placed the border in
correct
as a result Otzi was dug up by Austrian
authorities and taken to an Austrian
institution for study however two weeks
after this discovery on October the 2nd
a new survey was carried out which
determines that the mummy had actually
then located about 300 feet from the
border that's on the Italian side
therefore South Tyrol successfully
claimed property rights but agreed to
let the scientific examination of the
Iceman be carried out in Austria
consequently Otzi has been at the South
Tyrol Museum of Archaeology in Italy for
over two decades
[Music]
Otzi or the Similan man as he is
sometimes called is categorized as a wet
money this means that it's body was
dehydrated and lost most of its fluid
but the tissue and organs are still well
preserved odds these corpse has become
one of the most extensively analysed and
examined human remains in history and
believe it or not we are still learning
stuff about him and the age he lived in
we are fortunate that he was preserved
almost in his entirety because he ended
up in a crevasse that shielded him from
the harshest weather elements but also
perfectly encased him inside a glacier
and protected him from being crushed
during the glaciers movements as a
result of this we got an amazing glimpse
into the life the behavior the clothing
the tools and even the diet of primitive
Europeans from over 5000 years ago Otzi
was a relatively small man for the time
his mummy is a little over five feet
tall and weighs close to 29 pounds
in life he would have been a bit taller
something like 5 foot 2 and would have
weighed around 10 pounds by examining
structural bone units called osteons
from the mummies of femur researchers
estimated that at sea it was around 45
years old when he died most of his hair
was gone because the epidermis quickly
shed during the process of decomposition
however a few clumps were still present
around the remains indicating that odds
he had dark medium long hair with traces
of arsenic in it that last part suggests
to researchers that the Iceman was
involved in smelting most likely copper
since he had an axe blade that was
almost pure copper this belief was
further strengthened by the fact that
oxys lungs were blackened by soot due to
clothes prolonged exposure to open fires
Australian scientists from Canberra
examined the isotopes in Otzi's teeth
and bones to see what information they
could glean by studying the minerals
present in his body
researchers extrapolated the composition
of his drinking water and consequently
identified the places where he lived
they believed that they pinpointed his
origins fairly accurately and
unsurprisingly they're not far from the
site where he was discovered they
ascertained that the Iceman lived
somewhere in the valleys within 37 miles
south of his icy grave moreover they
detected contrasts in the compositions
of his tooth enamel which suggested that
at one point he left his childhood home
behind and moved around as an adult the
rest of his bone suggested that the
similar
man led a tough and physically active
lifestyle he had broken several bones
during his lifetime and x-rays revealed
that his shoulders knees hips and spine
all had significant wear and tear in the
drives one study indicated that the
Iceman's tibia showed medial lateral
strengthening well above the average for
the late Neolithic man something that
could have been indicative of long walks
over rough terrain this compounded with
the rest of the physical stress exerted
on his bones led to speculation that
Otzi may have been a high-altitude
shepherd
this should not come as much of a
surprise to you but Otzi was not a
particularly healthy individual at least
not by our standards in fact he
currently holds the distinction for
oldest evidence of Lyme disease and an
infectious illness which is transmitted
to humans by the Borrelia bacterium
spread by ticks scientists could not
tell how advanced the infection was but
it could have given the iceman joint
pains and severe headaches in addition
to his bacterial companion Otzi was
infested with tricker astre Currier
parasite better known as whipworm eggs
belonging to the parasite who were still
located in the Iceman's intestinal tract
perhaps the most curious medical
affliction that befell Odyssey was
severe arteriosclerosis this is the
hardening of arteries which scientists
previously regarded as a problem of the
modern world specifically it is usually
an issue for people who follow the couch
potato fast to your lifestyle as being
overweight and getting little exercise
were considered the major risk factors
alongside smoking and drinking and yet
Otzi feasted on no fast food and reposed
on no recliner but he was still a heart
attack waiting to happen as it turned
out he had a genetic predisposition for
arteriosclerosis something which plays a
bigger part in the condition than we
previously expected
Otsu was also lactose intolerance but
this was still the norm amongst late
Neolithic Europeans dairy products
represented a relatively new food group
and their systems were still learning to
process them in addition to all these
the Iceman also had a few peculiarities
that weren't necessarily bad just a bit
unusual he only had 11 pairs of ribs
instead of 12 he had an abnormally thick
bony Ridge above his eyes and he lacked
wisdom teeth the rest of his teeth you
won't be surprised to learn were full of
cavities and worn down most likely due
to his high carb grain heavy diet so all
in all odd C was not exactly the picture
of health
[Music]
speaking of his diet the ice man's
remains were so well preserved that they
still contained Otzi's last meal it
seems that just hours before he died the
similar one man gorged on a high-fat
feast that would but most fast food
menus to shame we don't know whether
this was a regular occurrence Part C or
whether he realized he was dying and
decided there was no point in letting
good food go to waste
most of the meal consisted of fatty ibex
meat in its condition it still had
striations on the meat fibers which were
a sign that it had been air-dried or
cooked at low temperatures to last
longer modern tests indicate that
boiling the meat or roasting it or
preparing it in any way using
temperatures over 60 degrees Celsius or
a hundred and forty degrees Fahrenheit
would cause that striated pattern to
disappear Otzi complimented his own
barracks meat with a summit of reindeer
we're not sure what part it was though
all the IBEX meat was clearly fatty
muscle the Red Deer matey ate was most
likely an organ like the spleen or liver
his stomach also contained traces of
einkorn wheat most curiously it appears
that the Iceman also feasted on a type
of fern called Bracken which is mainly
notable for being toxic researchers are
still a bit puzzled over this one and
haven't found a conclusive explanation
yet was it simply a mistake and hotseat
thought it was something else or did he
use it to wrappers me since then
accidentally ingested a few pieces it's
also possible that he used it as a
medicine to treat some sort of
stomachache or again maybe he just
realized he was dying and thought might
as well try it things gonna get any
worse
[Music]
an interesting aspect about the similar
in man's body was that it was covered in
tattoos originally scientists spotted
somewhere around 40 but that number
steadily increased as they continued to
inspect their remains closely and found
new ways of contrasting the black
tattoos against the dark leathery brown
skin as of the most recent mapping of
Otzi's body which took place in 2015
researchers have spotted 61 tattoos
grouped into 9 different sections the
tattoos themselves are very basic and
consist of black lines arranged either
in cruciform patterns or parallel to
each other they were probably made by
cutting small incisions into the skin
and then rubbing in charcoal admittedly
the tattoos didn't exactly turn Otzi
into the Illustrated man but scientists
are more interested in their purpose
rather than their quality were they
purely for decoration or did they have
some kind of symbolic or ceremonial
meaning or maybe it was a medical thing
the last option has really intrigued
researchers ever since they noticed that
all of the tattoos are grouped into
clusters and placed on Otzi's lower back
wrists ankles and knees all places that
suffered degeneration and were likely to
cause pain perhaps they were used as an
ancient pain relief treatment similar to
acupuncture only thousands of years
before the practice was used in China
we've covered about all there is to say
about odd C based on his remains but
there is plenty more to discuss when the
Iceman was first discovered he was
decked out in a full assortment of
clothing giving us a glimpse into late
Neolithic fashion what he was a man who
liked his leather and used skins and
hides from at least five different
animals to craft his outfit one of the
researchers who helped analyze and
recreate his clothing called him pretty
picky when it came to you selecting his
material so it seems that Otzi may have
been the earliest known fashionista in
history the IceMen was wearing a coat
leggings a loincloth a cloak a belt a
cap and shoes his loincloth with
sheepskin his leggings were made out of
goat hide and his coat was a mixture of
both goat and sheep hides that had been
stitched together with animal sign-u the
coat had been used for a long time as it
of makeshift prepares using grass
spiders his cloak was made out of woven
alpine swamp grass and his hat was a
fancy bearskin camp that even had a
chinstrap to keep it in place whether
the cloak was actually a cloak or not is
still a matter of debates as too little
of it survived to get an idea of its
full size and shape some have argued
that it could have been part of a
backpack or simply a map that the IceMen
unfurled when he wanted to sleep the
belt was made out of calf skin and had
another leather strip attached onto it
to make a small pouch which contained
several items that were going to talk
about in a minute Otzi also carried a
quiver manufactured from the leather of
a roe deer an impressive part of the
Iceman's outfit were the shoes they were
made out of two layers stitched together
the inner layer consisted of insulating
dry grass stuffed into a netting made
out of bast fiber string the outer layer
was deer hired worn with efair on the
inside a Czech footwear expert who
specialized in recreating ancient shoes
created replicas of Otzi's shoes and
gave them to experienced climbers to use
on mountain terrain they found that the
footwear was not only comfortable but
offered great protection and the
researcher even got an offer from a
Czech company that wanted to buy the
rights to sell the shoes
[Music]
the compliment is snazzy outfit odd see
it was also completely kitted out with
ancient gear the highlights of his
equipment was a copper axe which is
still to this day a one-of-a-kind
discovery the haft was approximately 24
inches long it was made from you and had
a right angled crook one ends to hold in
the blade the blade was 99.7% pure
copper and it was fixed into the shaft
of the handle with birch tar and tied
together with leather straps this tool
saw a lot of actions the blade showed
signs of being resharpened numerous
times this was clearly a valuable item
and similar axes from around that time
period have been found buried with
high-ranking men this led to speculation
about Otzi's origins maybe he had not
just been a Shepherd or a smelter maybe
he was someone of high status like a
tribal chief scientists actually managed
to trace the source of the copper and
found that it came from southern Tuscany
hundreds of miles from where the Iceman
was discovered even though the Alpine
region had its own copper ore sources
instead of writing answers they these
finds only seemed to deepen the mystery
around the similar one man there was
plenty more equipment in the ice man's
tool bag we already mentioned that he
had a quiver and it seems he was in the
process of assembling a full bow and
arrow set he had a long stave made from
you which she was carving into a
functional bow he also had 14 arrows
made from wayfaring tree and cornelian
cherry although only two of them had
been finished with arrowheads and
fletching the quiver also contains a few
antler tips and a long piece of bast
fiber which would have probably served
as the bowstring although not as
impressive as the copper axe but just as
unique were Otzi's dagger and retoucher
the dagger had a flint blade and an ash
wood handle and a wicker sheath and is
still the only fully preserved dagger
from the Copper Age the retoucher was a
tool that puzzled researchers for a
while as they couldn't figure out its
purpose it looked like a large pencil
made from a branch of lime tree and with
a sharpened core inside that turned out
to be a piece of fire hardened antler
they eventually realized that the
retoucher was used to resharpen other
tools and weapons another thirst for
that time period
else he also had on him two birch bark
containers which helped charcoal
fragments and various leaves given that
the inside of one container was
blackened researchers speculate that the
IceMen used them
carry embers around to start fires the
rest of the gear included a few pieces
of wood and rods and planks which were
once a part of a backpacker
bird belt used to carry fowl and two
pieces of birch fungus which were
threaded onto leather strips most likely
to be used as medicine now we arrived at
perhaps the biggest puzzle that still
surrounds our soup what cost is death
while sea caught in a blizzard did he
injure himself thus becoming unable to
return to his tribe before freezing to
death was he a ritual sacrifice
or was there foul play involved for a
decade after his discovery scientists
generally believed that Otzi died of
exposure to the elements it wasn't until
years later that a more advanced CT scan
of his remains revealed that the Iceman
had an arrow wounds beneath his left
collarbone moreover these shot at an
artery and caused massive blood loss
which would have caused Otzi to go into
shock and possibly suffer a heart attack
even today the trance of surviving an
attacker around 40% so the IceMen had
virtually no way of making it out alive
investigating his death as a regular
cold case detectives concluded that
pottsy's assailants got away with murder
signs pointed to an ambush just hours
before his death the Iceman enjoyed a
heavy meal so he wasn't in a rush there
were no defense wounds on his body
except a cut on his right hands which
was a few days old and had already begun
to heal at the time of his death as far
as motivation goes investigators ruled
out profit because the killer didn't
take pottsy's prized copper axe just
like their conclusions detectives
reluctantly admit that this is one cold
case destined to remain unsolved forever
someone may have taken out the Iceman
but they didn't take out his bloodline
believe it on an autopsy has descendants
that are still alive today when
scientists sequenced his genome back in
2013 they compared a unique genetic
mutation to thousands of samples
obtained from donors in tirol and found
that 19 of them shared the same ancestry
as Otzi they were all men as it appears
only the paternal line survived
[Music]
controversy seems to have followed odds
see even in death we already mentioned
that there was a little tiff between
Austria and Italy over who owned the
remains but that matter was solved
quickly and pales in comparison to the
legal dispute between the original
discoverers and the government of South
Tirol according to Italian law helmets
in Erika's Simon were entitled to a
finder's fee for locating the IceMen
equal to 25% of his total value however
the provincial government simply refused
to pay this arguing that they are the
ones who covered the expenses of
removing and preserving the iceman in
1994 they offered a measly reward of 10
million lira 5,200 euros unsurprisingly
the Simons refused and he went to court
it wasn't until 2008 17 years later that
the matter was settled
although Helmut Simon had died by then
his widow received 150,000 euros Ellmers
who died during a freak blizzard while
hiking not far from where the IceMen was
found was just one of several bizarre
deaths linked to Otzi prompting rumors
of a curse similar to one of the
Pharaohs of course given that hundreds
of people were involved in the discovery
and study of the frozen men having a few
of them died over the course of decades
is not very unusual even so the curse of
the Ice Man just helps to add to the
mystique that still surrounds Otzi so I
really hope you found that video
interesting and there's a little bit
different to the regular stuff we do
here on by graphics but if you did enjoy
it please give us a thumbs up let me
know what you thought in the comments
below also if you like this channel but
like stuff that's a little bit different
why not check out our sister channel
Geographics which is it's like bio
graphics except it's about geography I
will link to that below and as always
thank you for watching